beh questo lo deve dire ci siamo dati
sulla bestia dentro che un horror
veramente figo episodio 3 buona visione
center for your perfetto
la partenza più bella del pianeta
buongiorno morto morto la partenza morto
non si sa come sia possibile però ha
chiesto nel tempo è bello quando ci sono
quando ti fa cambiare punto di vista del
gioco che non mi ricordo più che non
sono io ma sono io indietro nel tempo
quindi le cose che sono successe prima
dovevo andare nel basement allora my
fathers belgio dalla stanza letto il mio
padre che penso sia di sopra intanto
piano ci sta cosa
asciuga flashlight tipo in amnesia vero
vero buongiorno quando succedono le cose
veramente a quando mi aveva buttato giù
dagli scali ricordate si si sia a posto
allora quindi buongiorno sono io quello
che hai buttato giù sono fregato sotto
la mia tesi lo sciame che emilius max
ionata locker
non sono il ben venuto qua tua madre
farmi prendere qualcosa lo sapremo
quindi è una specie di gioco dove
continuano ad alternare presente futuro
è passato il futuro passata e presente
ma non l'avete capito e mi avevano
buttato di sotto avevo visto delle cose
orribili quale dice anche la scopa delle
streghe ok accendino ma non voglio
sapere cosa c'è lì sotto la porca vacca
è vabbè dentro dentro la casa proprio
dentro il muro questa è la prima volta
che mi capita di star entro un muro di
una casa non è proprio il massimo
amore a che piano 61 e mezzo cioè io mi
sarei sempre immaginato i topi dentro i
muri non è proprio il massimo vabbè mi
sarei sempre immagino che se quella roba
da in fondo vedo un tizio torna indietro
torna indietro lo vedo già lo vedo già
non andiamo avanti lo vedo già lo vedo
già cessata na li c'e stata la torino
dove dice un tizio torna indietro se un
tizio morto così che sta la torna
indietro per l'amore di gesù torna
indietro fai così indietro indietro
indietro noi andiamo avanti andiamo da
satana ciao
buongiorno io sono uno stupido io vengo
ha salutato come fa lui come fa lui
fallo tu copia copia come ho fatto io
con più di parte ma dai ma veramente ma
l'avrebbe detto guarda ci vuole la
giusta colonna sonora per andare nel
basement ragazzi con qualcosa di dopo
più di tre mesi di pura vacanza e poi
ricomincia la scuola
se l'è bela vero una grave mancanza a
guardare il fantasma che vola ragazzi
miei io se non smorzarsi l'atmosfera
dell'horror a quest'ora avrei già 8
infarti però sarebbe un altro tutto un
altro questo qua il quadro di prima
senza che il cappello vero credo tanto
sta parte l'anno murata vacchi che la
murata non ho capito comunque abbiamo
chiuso ali sul lock peak posso aprire
beta con casinò permesso o il demonio
buongiorno allora ragazzi facciamo i
seri andiamo avanti ho qua non voglio
starci quindi prima facciamo meglio è
stacca le travi tanto e casa 2 1 della
roma ma chi è che chi è che mura le cose
il suo posto mi spiegate
mi chiamo se mons e mi spunta qualcuno
all'improvviso e che poi certo non è che
dici chissà se c'è qualcuno in casa mia
non l'hai visto che c'è qualcuno quindi
non insistere usciamo basta basta esci
dati fuoco fa qualcosa non andare sempre
negli stessi pop madonna brutto
va bene cosa sto vedendo lei non è messo
bene
la reazione proprio lui reagisce questo
c'è un machete bello grosso va beh ne
scende dal palco demonio porto si guarda
che io non sono quello che stavi
picchiando prima è sono un altro quali
non è che vede che sono clicchiamo tutti
perché non sono fuori prima sono un
altro scusi ma dov'è che cosa è successo
ma come boe vale non ho capito quindi
questa è l'amara e la mitica porta
quella tutta sbarrata che non che non
riusciva ad aprire neanche prima va bene
ragazzi ci dovrei aver fatto abbiamo
riaperto la porta va bene allora andiamo
andiamo andiamo a trovare sto tizio si
fa chiamare il giudice tra l'altro rende
dobbiamo seguire la traccia di sangue
barca vacca tutto in casa tua
io sarei orgoglioso ti giuro è uscito è
uscito di casa
qua siamo nel passato non cela qualcosa
degli spettri quindi va beh chiamo
andiamo a vedere dopo il pazzoide si è
infilato bello però il fatto che in casa
mia il succedono queste cose io non ne
sono neanche consapevole però vabbè ci
pensi che ma veramente ci sono delle
delle abitazioni intorno alla mia io
neanche lo sapevo prima davanti sto
gioco più scopro cose ma di un fucile
proietti beric era quello che aspettavo
dall'inizio la torre a fini frost
con la pistola in the wedding john kamm
nicole john mack
quasi
dai fammi spa raramente fari spararne a
me fa mi sparare toini togliermi questa
soddisfazione
io grazie infine a ma non è morto è
svanito nell'aria orco demonio aiuto
scherzavo
forse era meglio non sparare svanisce
nell'aria qui non lo puoi uccidere va
bene comunque trovato dei proiettili per
terra tipo in call of duty
va bene porca vacca ragazzi diventata
uno sparato bellissimo ai la bellissima
ma non sono sicuro che questa sia la
posizione giusta per tenere una pistola
ma fa niente comunque che anzi ai
ragazzi ma dramma
ormai
faccio io l'ho ucciso io che penso mi
fido
dove colpire ma cosa mi colpisce una
volta sono ma eccolo eccolo pronto per
niente il mio obiettivo e colpirono
miliardo di mondo siete delle teste di
culo voi tutti quanti ma devo dire
madonna un'ora e mezza o ce l'ha fatta
proprio lui ce lo fanno non è anche
schivato lascia che ma tirato perché nel
mentre malati nava l'ho colpito quindi
perfetto buongiorno posso aprire
comunque questa questo albergo tra
virgolette esiste anche nel nei giorni
nostri quindi posso tornarci anche
dall'altro palco che bello accogliente
sei morto
ora ci voleva tanto grazie allora tu hai
un amico ma dico subito
ma risalta la testa giù giù giù giù giù
ragazzi nella persona regatanti
guardiamo amici e famiglie sono proprio
un canale per voi non è colpa mia è lui
che cosa faccio io devo fare io gioco
gioco e così faccio col dei bit pronto
they are working finder quanto un cloud
va bene devo ancora cercare le tracce
porco demonio ma mia moglie in tutto
questo esiste ancora chi se non la senti
lei è lì sempre
hai visto c'è un tizio c'è gente che vi
sta bene
vabbè sceglie un lavoro migliore
mia moglie è sparita completamente la
pistola mi piaceva non puoi prenderlo
anche tu cavolo stavo di un tranquillo
che non avete idea miglior non posso mai
fare una sega invece va bene cerchiamo
le tracce
eccolo ma come vai vai vai apri veloce
segui la spia
porca vacca dragan dato corri corri e
non lo so dove andare un solo mandato
non vedo non vedo ecco lo marcava che
c'era una spia davvero a pezzo de
pervertito porca put vacca chiede ma chi
l'ha calciato a pervertito russo le
meego ioni di nico a pezzente schifoso
tipico con rampino dei pio
mi scusi lei sta arrivando
l'ho vista madonna che casino chissà
cosa è successo
puoi stare fermo in un punto che mamma
mia dove che è andato
dov'è
sei andato di qua ma com'è possibile
e andato di qua ma non è un fantasma
come è possibile non si sa dove sia
scappata possibile accordo ma come hai
fatto a parchi male dai che pirla audio
aprile ma ci vuole un codice no non ce
la farò mai trovarlo qui ragazzi siamo
arrivati fino qua cuculo episodio
speriamo che nel prossimo di riuscire a
trovare quella maledetta spia ed in fila
di tutto il tubo super voi sapete dove
per adesso spero che vide vi sia
piaciuto di schede a canestro del tasto
mi piace schiaccia della campanellina
che ci avete vicino ad esso iscriviti
che molto importante come sempre ci
vediamo belle ragazze
[Musica]